samuel leeds here i hope you are guys
and in this video i'm going to share
with you
four ways that you can buy property
without using any of your own
money so if you want to buy houses with
no money then stay tuned
[Music]
okay so the ways i'm about to describe
to you how you can buy properties
without using
any of your own money firstly i want to
say that i have done
all four ways so this is not stuff that
i'm talking about this is not theory
this is actual practical
uh i've been there i've done it not only
have i done it but i've helped
dozens and dozens of other people do it
as well by telling them what i did
so this is you know real life stuff
sometimes people say to me you can't buy
houses with no money
and i respond you're absolutely correct
you can't they can't because they don't
believe they can so i think the first
step is just being open-minded
people have been buying businesses with
no money for years using you know
all kinds of different uh agreements so
i'm gonna share these with you
and you can either you can be one of the
people types of people that say oh i
don't believe that's possible that's too
good to be true
and right kind of stuff in which case
that's fine maybe don't even continue
watching any more of the video
if you don't want but you know if you
think that's fine or you can be someone
that's just a little bit open-minded in
which case this could happen for you so
here's the first way number one is
lease option agreements now a lease
option agreement is
basically where you buy a property today
but you pay for it later so you could
almost say it's a little bit like the
owner
has given you a free loan for say five
years
when it comes to the end of the option
agreement you don't have to buy it you
have the option not the obligation
and in all that time and this is what
just blows my mind of how good lease
options are because i've got many lease
option agreements
so say you buy it today but you pay for
it in five years you're not putting
anything down today
okay you might you might have to pay for
the solicitor fees but you've not
actually put any money in for the
property at all
and you're getting immediate cash flow
and
as the house goes up in value you're
gaining from capital appreciation so
it's just a fantastic way
of getting your foot in the door owning
properties and doing this
starting out with no money if you want
to learn more about lease option
agreements i have done other videos
about this but
it's one of my favorites number two is
joint ventures now a joint venture is
where
two people come together they usually
will bring fifty percent of
value and they will put fifty percent of
value together
to do a venture a deal if your venture
is property and you're buying a property
and you'll do this as a joint venture
with somebody else
you've both got to bring 50 50 value but
you haven't necessarily got to bring 50
50 money
your value could be something that is
not actually cash
your value could be you're bringing the
deal to the table
you could be bringing your knowledge the
power team
the overseeing of the project there's
loads of things that you can bring
to the deal besides cash if you
find a joint venture partner who has
cash but that's it
i have nothing else they can't go on to
be successful
without you you tell them look
you put the money in we'll put the time
and the energy and the knowledge and the
team and all that
in and then we'll go 50 50 on the
profits
effectively you have bought a property
without using
any of your own money joint ventures
absolutely fabulous way to do it now
it's really
you need to be really careful if you do
a joint venture partnership
that you you have clear expectations and
clarity
so you know what's what in case it's a
case of you said this no i didn't so you
need to have proper contracts drawn up
and a clear understanding of what you're
both bringing to the table but joint
ventures is an incredible way to get
started with no money
and for that you can't be successful in
property
with no money no time no creativity
no implementation of course you need
something you can bring something to the
table but it doesn't have to be money
number three different to joint ventures
this is using other people's money
if you know how to buy a property and
make a 20
return on investment you also know
someone who's got a hundred thousand
pounds
sat in the bank doing nothing you could
borrow their money
to buy property give them a fixed return
so you could give them five percent ten
percent return on investment on their
money which is way better than the bank
and then any extra you're going to keep
yourself and you've also obviously got a
free property
so it doesn't have to be your money you
can use somebody else's this is very
different to a joint venture because a
joint venture
has a stake in the property other
people's money number three that could
also be
the bank's money you could get a bank
loan to put down to buy a property it
doesn't matter where the money's come
from it's just it's someone else's
besides yours
so it's a case of tapping into money i
have personally
myself i'm not recommending this but i
have bought
properties on credit cards i've
literally
gone to the bank with credit cards maxed
out
and used the cash to put down deposit on
properties
and then switched the debt on the credit
card over to a zero percent credit card
so i'm not even paying interest on the
debt that's other people's money you've
got to be careful doing this because you
need to know what you're doing you don't
want to borrow money from friends and
family and and
and then screw it up but if you know
what you're doing and you understand how
to buy properties
i think using other people's money is a
much smarter way of using your own
because you've you're going to get an
infinite return on investment that way
and number four of how how to buy
properties and own properties
without using any of your own money is
by buying a property
adding value to it and then refinancing
the property you don't even need much
money
to start with because you can get a
bridging loan some of my students are
doing this right now as we speak
very successfully whereby they're buying
properties they're borrowing
all the money on a bridging loan to buy
their property they're then adding value
to the property and again borrowing
money to do that
so the whole thing they're borrowing
people you know banks money to do it but
then when the project is completed
and they've added value they're then
refinancing the property on
with a new lender and the money that
they get they're paying off all the
loans and then they've got now got a
property that they've put none of their
own money down for
i mean you might end up leaving a little
bit of money in if you do it right you
can leave no money in i've done this
successfully uh
several times where i've left no money
in with buying and refinancing
on bridging on bridging loans that's
just four ways that you can
buy properties without using any
of your own money i hope that's been
inspiring i hope that's been helpful
if this has opened your mind up or this
has really got you thinking then why
don't you
do your friends and family the favor and
share the video around and open their
minds up too because i'm on a mission
to really open up people's minds and to
get people out the old way of thinking
which is save up put money in a bank
work really hard put a deposit on a
house
that old way of thinking which is
leading to people buying their first
house when they're in their 30s and 40s
which it really doesn't need to be like
that so i'm on a mission
share the mission share the video thank
you so much i love you very much peace
out thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share with your family and friends for
more videos like it you can watch right
here
and if you'd like to spend two days with
me at the property investors crash
course
watch this video see what happens but
whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe
right here and i'll see you next time